a Conservative MP has filmed himself
bearing all on a bicycle in order to
promote an annual naked charity cycle
Michel fabricant is aiming to raise
money for the said Giles Hospice in his
constituency of Lichfield which he says
cost nine million pounds a year to run
in a video posted online the 68 year old
rides a rented London bicycle around a
park wearing only sunglasses and a
silver tie have a look today I'm
launching a campaign to start an annual
naked cycle ride in Litchfield why
because we've got the fabulous st. Giles
Hospice which looks after over seven
thousand people each year but it costs
nine million pounds to run and I think a
naked cycle ride is a good way of
raising money a naked bike ride from
Litchfield to Whittington would be a
beautiful thing I would uncover all
sorts of parts that I've never seen
before
I'm told that naked cycle riding is both
healthy and liberating bit like st.
Charles hospice really
and mr. fabricant joins us now I'm
anxious to look round whether or not
he's got any coal yes he has thank
goodness for that hello to you mr.
fabrikam thanks for joining us on sky
news this afternoon tell us why you how
you came up with this idea well I've
been in various parts around the world
not looking for naked cycle rides I
hasten to add but where I've encountered
naked cycle rides because it goes on in
about 70 different cities throughout the
world and it just struck me would be a
good way of promoting st. Charles
Hospice in litchfield covers a large
area of the West Midlands but it's based
in Whittington near Litchfield and I
just saw is a great way to raise money
and put up the blood pressure of some of
my constituents maybe people who say
you're just being an exhibitionist well
what's wrong with that if it's all for
charity but I must tell you it was
freezing during that video we did it in
early spring and you can see the
goosebumps on me and it was terrible
ok so what's the plan um do you want
other people to take part with you
thankfully you kept your tie on do you
want other people to take part with you
yeah yeah I'm hoping we might get
100-200 people taking part every year
you know we have the sheriff's ride with
fully clothed people on horses so I
think a few naked people on bicycles
going around Litchfield and maybe ending
up in Whittington was a great idea of
raising money but I'm not going to be
doing the organizing so people who know
about this sort of thing they'd like to
make contact with my office that would
be fantastic
are you always going to be taking part
not necessarily but I promise that if it
all happens I'm certainly going to do
the first ride well you know be a little
bit embarrassed in front of your
constituencies literally laid bare
letting it all hang out as they say well
I have to say that when we recorded that
little video as I said way back in the
spring it was also cold nothing was
hanging out I can tell you it was you
know I don't know with you've never had
a tortoise and you know that the head
goes back inside the shell well it was a
little bit like that right I think
that's more information than I'll ever
need in my whole life
tell me about the hospice she said
quickly tell us about the work that they
do know is marvelous they look after
7,000 people every year 80% of them in
their own home people who have got
particular dysfunctions and those who
have got terminal dysfunctions like
cancer they've got I think they were one
of the first if not the first place in
the whole of the country to have a
lymphedema clinic which is very
important for those people who had lymph
glands removed it's a really great
organization and as I say two-thirds of
the money that costs to run the
operations some 6 million pounds has to
be raised locally through charity